انا
الوفد الامريكي
هذه المفاوضات التي بدات في جده هدفنا من
هذه المحادثات
ركز بشكل اساسي اولا على تامين الاتفاق
لاعلان المبادئ الانسانيه
ثم وقف اطلاق النار طويل وكافي لتسهيل
الايصال المتواصل للخدمات الضروريه جدا
اذا نجحنا في هذه المرحله وتحدثوا مع
فاوضين صباح اليوم البنهم متفائلون بحذر
هذا سيمكن من توسيع المحادثات مع المزيد
من اصحاب الشان
الاقليمين والدوريين لوقف العداءات الدائم
ثم العوده الى الحكم المدني كما طالب
الشعب السوداني منذ سنوات نحن وشركاءنا
نستمر بالتوضيح للاطراف المقاتله التي
يقودها الجنرالان انه لن يكون هنالك حل
عسكري لهذه الازمه والتفاضه
قدما كما اوضحنا وكما ذكر تم سيدي الرئيس
عبر
القرار الاداره لرئيس بايدن
اننا سوف نحملها على المسؤولين
اللي ما حصل في السودان هذه السلطه
قرات الجداد تعكس العالم بان العالم ما
يراقب
والقتال يجب ان يتوقف
يحاسب المسؤول نحن دور السعوديه لاستضافه
هذه المحادثات وسوف نستمر بالعمل عنقر مع
كافه الشركات الاقليمين من ضمنهم الاتحاد
الافريقي ورباعيه السودانيه تشمل بريطانيا
لانهاء هذا الميزان سيدي الرئيس اذا ما
سمحت لي
في هذا السياق اود ان اشكركم على
ارسال
سفيرتنا الى اتحاد الافريقي واتكم على
تاكيد وجودها وعلى رغم العديد من النكسات
سوف نستمر بالوقوف الى جانب الشعب
السوداني في مطالبتهم للمستقبل الديمقراطي
والسلمي هم يستحقون افضل اشكركم واتطلعوا
للغايه الى اسئلتكم انت
والعضو رشه ما كان يجب ان نستغرق 100 يوم
وانا المذنبه ولن يتكرر ذلك
رئيس
الذي ساتي اليه الظرف الانسانيه منذ سته
عشر من ابريل ولكن تقارير الاوليه سيئه
70% من المستشفيات في المناطق النزاع لا
تعمل اكثر من ثلاث ملايين امراه وفتاه في
خطر العنف الموجه للنساء اكثر من 19 مليون
شخص في اخر تحليلاتنا
الغذائي خلال سته اشهر القادمه اذا استمر
القتال اكثر من 700 الف شخص نجحوا داخليا
واكثر 170 الف
اجتاز والحدود الى دول الجوار واثار هذه
الحرب ان لم تنتهي في حدود السودان بل
امتدت الى المنطقه وتفاقمت الاحتياجات
الانسانيه عبر عده دول
الولايات المتحده اكبر ما نحن مساعدات
الانسانيه للسودان
ومع ان سياقه تغيير
المساعدات الى الشعب السودان لم يتغير في
23 ابريل
اعلنت ان الشراب الطريقه استجابه للكوارث
الى المنطقه لقياده تنسيق استجابه
الولايات المتحده الانسانيه مع بعض
البرامج الموقفه
تعلقت مؤقتا في 19 مشاركائنا من اصحاب
الشركات العالميه قويه يستمرون بالعمل
بقدرات اقل
بدايه النزاع الفرق الوطنيه
واللجان ومنظمه المجتمع المدني اثرت شجاعه
كبيره استجابه للاحتياجات في مجتمعاتهم
واهجهم مخاطره كبيره احد شركاءنا نشر
الشبكة من
قبيلات لتوفير الدعم
خلال الولاده
ضمن القصف الجوي ومن صعب السفر الى العديد
من المستشفيات شجاعتهن وشجاعه الشعب
السوداني انقتل الارواح وانجبوا الكثير من
الاطفال تحت ظروف قاهره على الرغم من
التقدم البطيء فانا
صعبه الوصول الى المناطق وعدم وجود المؤن
والاموال
الاتصالات والكهرباء سياخ قدرته على
استدامه تقديم مساعدات خلال اسابيع
المقبله نحن اتطلعوا العمه 10 كان
الاستجابه الان حتى مع تقي من المساعدات
الانسانيه الضروريه التقييمات سريعه
مستمره ونعمل مع الشركاء الان لاستخدام
البرامج الحاليه
تعزيز البرامج الطارئه كما نعمل عن قربه
اما عشره كان بالذات الخارجيه والامم
المتحده لمناعه في جده للظروف التي ستسمح
لنشر العمليات الانسانيه من ضمنها البرامج
البريه والجويه من الدول الجوار كما طالب
والكانات الحكوميه في السودان ودول الجوار
لخفض العواقل البيروقراطيه التي تعيق وصول
الاستجابه الانسانيه
لمتابعتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات